Iran said overnight it will stop
complying with some parts of the nuclear
deal now this is one year to the day
after President Trump walked out and
walked away from the landmark agreement
ron's president also threatened to
resume enriching uranium if countries
that are still part of the deal do not
come up with better terms within 60 days
Iran's economy is under pressure from US
sanctions this week the u.s. began
moving b-52 bombers in an aircraft
carrier Strike Group to the Persian Gulf
region David Martin is at the Pentagon
David good morning good morning
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo canceled
a trip to Germany in order to pay a
surprise visit to Baghdad in order to
brief Iraqi leaders on what the Pentagon
calls specific and credible threats
against US forces in addition to threats
in Iraq the US has also detected Iran
moving short-range missiles on boats in
the Persian Gulf as if they were being
put in position to be launched against
American forces based in Qatar Bahrain
or Saudi Arabia these so-called threat
streams prompted the u.s. to send a
carrier Strike Group and bombers to the
Persian Gulf the first of four b-52s is
expected to arrive at the main air base
in Qatar today and the aircraft carrier
Lincoln and its escorts are expected to
pass through the Suez Canal by tomorrow
this latest confrontation comes exactly
one year after the Trump administration
withdrew from a deal Iran signed with
the US and five other countries to
temporarily freeze its nuclear program
the Iran deal is defective at its core
other signatories to the nuclear deal
have 60 days to help Iran sell oil and
gain access to international banking
services otherwise Iran will scale up
its uranium enrichment program that
would technically mean the end of the
agreement we were able to get that very
frightening program into a box
Jarett Blanc was the State Department
coordinator for Iran nuclear
implementation under President Obama
walking away from that and threatening
that non-proliferation achievement it
threatens everybody a 60-day clock is
now ticking if Iran withdraws from the
nuclear agreement it will consider
itself free to begin enriching uranium
to bomb grade levels Dale David Martin
thank you very much